[Musica]
ciao ragazzi bentornati suoni the
stories vitale è qua dietro che si sta
travestendo da zucca vi ricordate che si
doveva travestire da zucca per cercare
di scoprire chi è jack o lantern il capo
delle zucche e cercare di farli andare
via da qua da casa nostra
beh ha detto che ha in mente un piano
geniale grazie per averci consigliato
tutti i nomi e mi raccomando prima di
iniziare lasciate un bel mi piace su
questo video per vedere nuove avventure
paurose e strane e divertenti
e se non mi segue ancora su instagram
per schermi suisa ne ha vissuti top ei
vitale zucca mi sono stato nella borsa
ciao solo sale sale sale in zucca
devo dire che sei bellissima il primo
era un fiore funzione di zucca
travestimento è fantastico
tranne a berlino che sto cercando di
mangiarti gli organi mezzino pero
secondo me potrebbero cascarci ma forse
di video scontri un po la testa perfetto
secondo voi ci capiranno soprattutto le
vostre proposte al testo di zucca
zuccone zucchina io volevo che farmi
zucchina però effettivamente le
dimensioni le dimensioni non lo
permettono quindi se non sembra proprio
una zucchina piccola semmai lo zucchero
zuccone sirene ora dobbiamo attuare il
nostro piano devi andare in mezzo alle
zucche e far vita di essere uno di loro
scoprire chi è jack e vedere che cosa
vogliono che porta altrimenti ci sentono
ragioni delle regole molto importanti
sono mi raccomando non devi mai dire di
essere vitale non devi mai dire che hai
fame vuoi mangiarti le zucche non devi
mai dire che vuoi fare il risotto di
zucca devi pensare come loro ok sono giù
ma devi pensare come loro le zucche
cattive
sono una zucca e vitale procura chiese
graziato forse berlino posso che evitare
sia una vera zucca cattiva bene se siamo
riusciti a confondere merlino riusciremo
a confondere anche di zuccheri abbiamo
sentito no cosa qualcuno puntato forse
solo le aree remote saranno già arrivate
le zucche qua tieniti pronto nel caso
l'istituto solo una sbirciata attento
berlino c'è un biglietto hanno lasciato
2 calderoni un biglietto vediamo cosa
c'è scritto
obiettivo trovare gli ingredienti di
slime se non riuscite a creare lo slime
verrete bolliti in una zuppa oppure
incisi trasformati in una lampada
deciderà il capo jack firmato i nuovi
proprietari di questa casa le zucche o
no vogliono bollire in una dopo a
trasformarsi in una lampada come
facciamo noi ad halloween con loro
effettivamente dobbiamo trovare gli
ingredienti slime dai siamo bravi in
questa è la mia morte un sacco di volte
lo dobbiamo dividerci lo devi
assolutamente andare da jacko che
scoprire chi è ma per poi rubare gli
ingredienti tra i posso farcela
sicurezza travestito mi raccomando
ritornati le regole senza mandato della
zucca niente
io invece prendere questo calderone con
me e raccoglierà tutti gli ingredienti
che trovo o crederemo che poi ci lascino
in pace anche se mi sembra una trappola
però proviamoci lo stesso con la fortuna
ciao ciao e buona fortuna
speriamo che vada tutto bene o vitale
vero berlino triestina lui andò il tuo
vicino
comunque noi non possiamo perdere tempo
dobbiamo trovare tutti gli ingredienti
slime e sperare che così si lascino in
pace le zucche anche se mi sembra molto
strano
andiamo merlino mi aiuti a cercare gli
ingredienti slam ea difendermi dalle
zucche ball e b che non mi sembra che
marino abbia molta voglia di aiutarmi
preghiamo ci potrebbe essere prendano
come ostaggio vitale andiamo state in
studio
vediamo dove sono le zucche
ci sono delle truppe laggiù ma sono
girate
spero che non si accorgeranno teme
berlino
prima critiche ma canzoni gli altri
adesso chi sto vitale come se la sta
cavando st giornate in studio non c'è
più la zucca sul letto
no non è per te questo
[Musica]
guardate sotto il trucco
riuscita a prendere un sacco di cose
anche se non ho tutto ho trovato
bicarbonato sacco di glitter e color
avanti la spatola
ora manca solo la soluzione parlanti la
colla sicuramente staranno insieme alle
altre zucche giganti dove vitale
vogliamo che sia riuscito a trovare jack
ha come bacio a passare chi non ce la
faccio prendono in quota ok sabato al
passato
[Musica]
zucche ecco lo zucchero
ora mi abbasso per convincerli di essere
una zucca come loro
[Musica]
io voglio unirmi a voi vogliono essere
una cattiva come vuoi ma perchè non
parlate zucchero non mi sembrano come
quelle a torino
capozzucca suo voglio già quanto il
ragga la zucca tu chi sei e cosa mollo
ma non farmi vivere tu una zucca come
noi
mi sembri una zucca marcia qualche altro
trattato se vuoi diventare una zucca
come noi beh allora dovrai superare la
pericolosissima prova dell'azzurro se il
bronzo si cerca la pace
[Musica]
allora no tuo nuovo da superare sarà
diretto da questa candela in pancia
proprio come noi tutto e zucca abbiamo
una candela in pancia anche tu dovrai
avere questa la sua prova finale se la
superi diventerai una zucca cattiva come
noi e adesso vai a mangiare la candela
mangio lavoro
ciao sono riuscito a prenderla come la
lettera tutti gli ingredienti per
crearlo e poi come dicevano loro ma sei
riuscito a scoprire chi e jack jack
koman e tra loro peso le zucche si
nasconde tra loro proviamo a creare lo
slime un racconto un tacco di
ingredienti nel frattempo ma si aspetta
qui non c'erano le zucche cattive che mi
hai fatto di loro legate
[Applauso]
brava bel colpo è bravissimo a trovare
queste cose ma dovremo nascoste io nel
frattempo faccio il claim velocemente
magari riuscirà a sconfiggerli la colla
alla soluzione per lenti e analizzare le
zucche
ma quali zucchetti le zucche che erano
dirà il corridoio quelle che bloccano le
entrate hanno fatto un campo base di
zuccheri e hanno stabilito il loro
quartier generale lì in mezzo in mezzo a
loro c'era sia questa folla qui che la
soluzione per l'est messe una colla ora
ha un sacco di altri ingredienti chissà
come sino questo time con tutte queste
cose di schiappe sì perché mette sempre
di fare una pozione dentro a questo caso
è l'orto momento stai dicendo che hai
fatto arrabbiare i jack come faccio ad
arrivare qua senza essere scoperto e
fatto prendere una cosa vuol dire che
stanno per arrivare
voleva permettere una candela accesa
nella mia pancia da zucca lara ti stanno
cercando ora dobbiamo sbrigare le guarda
quante cose ci sono dentro posti letto
gli ingredienti di una pozione mettiamo
tutti questi glitter ora provo mischiare
il tutto il colore strano nuovo il pieno
di twitter
ok sbrighiamoci soluzione per lenti
bicarbonato di sodio e poi dovrebbe
uscire la pozione c'è riuscito wow
dal momento non sembrano time stregato
tipo è bellissimo perché colore strano
che visito wow sembra un po donato un po
rosa
ho aggiunto un ingrediente speciale che
ingrediente speciale
cos'è quello veleno per piante supererà
piante o un piano non ti preoccupare
penso che funzionerà il mio piede e
jacqueline imolese quello lassù in alto
guardavo le più grande non usate più
prendervi gioco di mac stupidi umani ei
jack dolcetto o scherzetto
[Musica]
brega di questo jack
[Applauso]
e allora si vuole la data per la zucca
per festeggiare si tocca lasciate un bel
mi piace per oltre al giorno avventure e
se questo video raggiunto i 30 mila mi
piace strano treviso si trova gli
inglesi in line con sale di zucca con il
personaggio decidete voi prima di noi
nei commenti ora nella sua compatta
cartellina pubblicato perchè delle rotte
altri video linkato su quella parte di
te ma dov'è che ora puoi anche tornare
normale dice bisogni fila centro gesto
questo che la zucca successo scherzo
aiuto vitale rivorrebbe a nicosia
[Musica]